wild cards actually began out of a
role-playing game that we were playing
in and as I said in one of my other
sessions here we were playing a
superhero role-playing game and it
became addictive and we wasted like a
year and a half on it and we finally
said I got to figure a way to get some
money out of this so we made it a share
more of them ecology and you know 30
years later it's still going strong so
it's exactly 30 years later came up with
something pretty cool there that's that
amazes me 22 books in 2034 coming out
later this year and re more just fine so
excellent still with which worked or Han
fantastic but keeping that larger group
of authors and that larger universe and
that many characters going the wild card
trust would must have been very
important in that how did you set that
up well I was I was fortunate in that by
the time we came up with wild cards
there was several other shared world
anthologies going and they I don't know
if a lot of young people here are
discussing young people but you may not
remember the 80s but in the late 80s in
the late eighties the shared world
anthology was very trendy there was a
series called thieves world that Robert
Robert Lin aspirin and and Robert
aspirin and Lin a be edited together and
that was very very popular it was it
actually began as an argument in the bar
and it got a Worldcon about who would
win Conan or Elric you know from the
desire to see CDs great heroes in the
same universe together meeting each
other and they invented this fantasy
shared world thieves world it was so
popular that everybody started doing
shared worl anthologies and thieves
world was the most successful but there
was also glia vaca there was if car and
there was heroes in hell and it was war
world and got a a Jana Graystone Bay you
know they were horror shared worlds of
science fiction shared worlds and
fantasy share ports and we did the
superhero shared world but we were like
number six in
trend here and so therefore I was able
to talk to ask for them a B in thieves
world and find out all the horrible
things that had gone wrong with that
book and they weren't prepared since
they would have pioneers they didn't
know the kind of problems that could
arise and they had to fix them retro
actively and they'd come up with this
Master Agreement to finally they had to
pay lawyers you know many tens of
thousands of dollars to draw up for them
because you know and we were able to get
their Master Agreement for free and I
was essentially just copied it with a
few twists and we started out on a sound
basis unlike unlike thieves world and
we'd have the problems they had so with
that generosity and the willingness to
share so we would fall down the same
rabbit holes and break our legs that
helped us keep wild clubs together we
had our rules firmly in place from the
beginning the thing is that you know
writers when when you write assertable
a strange contradictory creatures on one
sense they're they they're all immensely
egomaniacs and on the other hand they're
also massively insecure and you know you
get the two two contradictory sides
flipping them and and when they're in a
book with other writers where your
characters are meeting their characters
everybody is identified with their
characters and wanting to win and and if
you don't know the rules set out very
quickly has happened in thieves world
you get a series of endless
one-upmanship sort of people I'm not
necessarily working together but
competing with each other and thieves
world had a very simple you know a
shared world the whole premise is you're
sharing the world with and your
character can meet their character and
you can use their characters in your
stories so these were all had a rule is
that you could not kill anyone else's
named character that was their rule you
know you can you can use everybody else
well the other writers for the book you
can use their characters but you cannot
kill anyone else's named character
which is fine as far as it goes but it
doesn't go far enough because when when
the writers got it to feel in pissy and
competitive you had things like my
character kidnaps your characters and
chops off your character's arms and legs
see I didn't kill them
so I'm within the rules I can do that
and now that you have a character that
has no arms and legs and you are there
was a character Robert aspirins own
character the an attorney anthology had
a character who was like the head of the
Mafia in a city where thieves world was
sent you know he would he had these army
he was the criminal that she for the
criminal underworld and he had like a
thousand Hawk masks that those were his
foot soldiers they were Hawk masks and
they enforced his rule so one of the
other writers killed all of the hawk
masks all like thousand of them because
they weren't named characters you see so
now you're the head of the Mafia but
there is no mafia your dark Corleone but
you got no one to give orders to that's
so this is the kind of crap that the
thieves world guys we're always doing to
each other and it you know it doesn't
necessarily produce for the best of
fiction and alleged a lot of conflict in
the group so having since they shared
all these stories with us we were able
to set up rules to prevent it and kept
wildcard on a scene or course how do you
how do you go about plotting one of your
three book series on that what we come
up with a general idea and you know then
I kind of refined that idea and I lay
out what we call the over plot which is
a the plot that unifies all three books
and that we'll run through it and and I
call four stories and you know I have
like 40 writers in a consortium I only
put eight stories in a book so people
pitch me ideas and I say yeah this one
will fit with that one will fit with
that one I put
together and and then the people who
stories don't fit I don't find their
shortage for that book so the last few
years you've added some different others
to the group and what we're gonna
continue to do that how how do you pick
and choose who's going to be part of the
the project I try to pick you know good
writers who number one who I think can
work well with others that's a big
criteria for welfare because as Steve's
will prove there are some writers who
can't work well with others who who are
best just left to write their own books
and you know we can enjoy them but don't
ask them to to try to play with any of
the other children and also we want
writers who are who love superheroes
comic books you know someone has always
had a frustrated desire to be Stanley it
is usually a good thing but the same
time want to bring their own thing to it
and who has some you know we don't want
to pick someone who has a soul in these
stories or some were sold one story to a
lot of people who have at least some
sort of a name who can hopefully bring
us new readers who oh you know I'm a fan
of Harry and now Harry's ready for well
cards I got this wild bird thing so they
bring new readers into it the series
grows in that minute Neil Gaiman tells a
story about pitching a character to you
for wild cards and having it turned down
yeah yeah that was right at the
beginning of series nobody knew he was
Neil Gaiman he was just this weedy
British kid dressed on black and he came
up and he pitch me to Sandman character
and I said now I know we got enough
bright side blue off mr. Gaiman but I
was probably mistaken he can laugh about
it now though yeah it was actually
probably the best thing I could have
done him because I you know wildcards as
successful as it is doesn't approach the
success of Sandman and had he written a
series of short stories for me for a
while quite series he he might not be
Neil Gaiman today I mentioned how how
vast the wild cards world is 22 books
now and it's it spans the globe there
are hundreds of characters and you have
same issue with the Westeros so many
characters and so much going on it so
much history how do you how do you keep
track of this you know what is what you
use for your Bible yeah I mean we do
have reference books and I of course I
have files on the computer and all that
but almost a lot of it is just animated
I know that both sources have large
wiki's online do you do you go to that
yourself I don't I know you know I'm old
school so well this wiki stuff is
foreign to me most of my own devices I'd
still be tying messages to the legs of
Ravens how much research goes into to
one your projects well it depends on the
project
I mean Westeros of course I've always
been a fan of history and I read a lot
of history of always read a lot of
history so that's what it's it's based
on and I research particular points if I
need particular points now something
like wild card now for example inside
straight one of the wild card books had
large sequences in in Egypt so I did a
fair amount of research about Egypt in
this geography in its cities and
you know where the dams were and you
know maps and etc etc to make sure as
editor if everybody was kind of on the
same page there for something like Ice
and Fire do you go so far into into
research that you you work out the
orbital dynamics of the planet to figure
out know how winter falls okay that's
probably good it's magic that's good
magic so it's a magic winter not a
science winter that's right that
actually tells us a lot